[Music]
all right so i know i'm in a room full
of men
but i still think this this story here
is quite interesting
so this 22 year old speak for yourself
some are boys here
that's what he was trying to say speak
for yourself is that what we said that's
what you said
i am speaking for myself i was
contextualizing no i'm just i'm just
saying nonsense for fun yeah you're
doing the job can i
adopt like 14th century law and say i
speak for my wife
no okay anyway okay listen this 22 year
old
argentinian woman decided to get her
fallopian tubes
tied because she says that
she knows for a fact she never wants to
have children
and when she went about to go find a
doctor to try to do this
because it's irreversible huh uh no i'm
thinking high in the fallopian tubes is
reversible actually
just untie it you tie it with the knot
that has a bow on it
brand new though there's gonna be like
way more complications
yeah there could be kinks you know you
might not be able to get pregnant
you don't know people like often save
their eggs too when they do that
they freeze some on the side she's like
doctor check this out i'm trying to get
mad cream pies but no
babies yeah well she says that ever
since ever since about high school
she she had already thought like she
already knew
yeah she got to figure it out she never
wants to be a mom but she loves getting
loads dumped in here yeah entire [ __ ]
there and she's all like and i love
unprotected sex
i ain't trying to take no pills [ __ ]
with my hormones just
she's the columns don't feel the same
it's not right let's cut it off so the
sole purpose
of cream pies she went on his journey of
trying to find a way to tie her too it's
a beautiful story yeah and then well
so she so she says that
for her she considers parenthood to be
more of a cultural
imposition rather than a natural
instinct
what cultural what work position
position
cult like society is what influences us
to want to have kids
not natural instincts damn right it does
they literally make it
so you save money on taxes if you have
them true
isn't it biological to want to [ __ ]
though to [ __ ] but to actually become a
parent
and to procreate although nobody wants
to do that but that's just kind of what
happens when you bust
nuts well some people live to do that my
friend yeah yeah i mean not nobody wants
it
no one expects it right i'm talking
about in the past like when we're
cavemen right
like we're just wired to [ __ ]
biologically so she's
saying like things that are kind of
crazy yeah like scientifically
we have a natural inclination to want to
propagate the species
which is to happen societally we are
pressured constantly to have children
and that's that's true too
so so both statements to me which is
nature versus nurture
argument is happening here right where
she says that it's completely all
nurture
and then i'm leaning more toward i think
it's nature i i think it's both in this
thing it could be uh
it is social pressure especially on
women because that becomes their
identity too like when are you gonna be
a mother and when
yeah so your parents are on your ass
right and then even from
from childhood like girl little girls
are playing with dolls
like we're like already being trained to
want to be mothers but
culturally trained not naturally
instinctually according to her
wanting to be mothers and boys are
naturally
trained to be killers because we have
boy dolls that want to kill other dogs
that guy's such a pansy he wants to play
in his kitchen all day how cute
he has a little kid these [ __ ]
grilling bell peppers and [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] tight because he sees you
cooking probably [ __ ] i'm a little [ __ ]
okay ass down with the panties i'm not a
parent yeah
you need to buy them some gi joes dude
gonna be in the garage
i know i had a mcdonald's kitchen as a
kid but somehow i managed to avoid
working there
so far but you managed to eat there all
the time you know what i'm saying
oh see they actually don't like
mcdonald's that much i wish i did
what yeah i don't i thought you would be
a mcdonald's man no
no i don't like it either i know it's
sad at home because like when when
tyka's playing pretend
he goes papa i'm gonna make you some
food oh cool what are you gonna make me
he goes a surprise
so he'll take his vegetables and he just
throws it all in the microwave and it
closes it
so i'm like is that what he thinks
cooking is he watches me just use the
microwave and he thinks that's cooking
oh
that's funny he takes like bell pepper
[ __ ] tomatoes and the cheese and he
closes the microwave he becomes the fake
microwave i assume yeah
his fake one his little he has a little
kitchen that's like two feet tall that's
cute
no he has a he uses a real one and he
climbs inside too okay that's good
that's good um no but going back to what
you were saying joe so like the caveman
days
it made me think of did you guys ever
see the movie the blue lagoon
the 1970s movie with um familiar but i
found hank's movie
oh never mind no that's castaway no no i
was looking at the mermaid you mean
the senior citizens when they start
swimming in that pool that the alien has
and then they become young again
no okay never mind blue lagoon i've
never seen it oh my god this one sounds
like a paul walker movie the chick that
was in it
was like famous for life because she was
in it what the [ __ ] was her name
brook shields brook shields was in it oh
let's see the poster okay but what about
it though i'm a big fan of brooklyn
what about the what happened in the
movie that they had sex on an island
they were deserted
yeah they were both like really hot
people okay listen
this is the blue lagoon okay movie and
during this movie because joe reminded
me of what happened in this movie which
was so they were cousins i think or
brother and sister
that's disgusting somehow related i
forgot how they've been doing since back
then
no but they got deserted on this side or
like yeah deserted on this island with
their uncle i think
when they were really little kids and so
they survived on this island
together and then they went through
puberty together and then they like the
boy like you see them like exploring
like oh [ __ ] like i have a boner
like what is happening here and then
it's like oh [ __ ] and then they start
kissing and then they start having sex
[ __ ]
and then but their sister brother i
forgot how but they're somehow related i
think
um but anyway pretty key information i
think makes a big difference but what
about it though
okay so then you see like she's like
what the [ __ ] like what's
going on in my stomach like what did he
start doing sit-ups like she didn't know
that she was
pregnant she didn't know that she was
about to have a baby because they don't
know that busted nuts can do that
that's true man oh they were cousins
they were cousins okay and then so
yeah and then like you see her like
trying to figure out like what the [ __ ]
is going on with me and then she ends up
giving birth by herself and like one of
the tiny little lagoons
and then they end up like having this
baby and they're just like holy [ __ ] now
we have to take care of another person
like it was just all very like like
discovery like it was never like
i want to have a baby you know like
you're right like it's not really
instinctual i guess but yeah so
anyway so then that's what she's saying
like she's never had that like
wanting to be a a mom ever so
anyway back to the point where she was
trying to go get this procedure done so
she goes to doctors
and these gynecologists and
because of because her views were are so
controversial in argentina apparently
gynecologist refused to do this
procedure for her she needs to go to a
vet she's going to the wrong
kind of doctor they know they're used to
that [ __ ]
they're like we get it we neuter [ __ ]
all the time standard procedures
they even sent her so they refused to do
it and they
sent her to go see a psychologist
instead because she's crazy
oh [ __ ] yeah they thought she's like no
i just saw blue lacoon
so like why do you want to ruin your
life you know you need to have a baby
nothing beats when somebody's trying to
back up their point with like no have
you read that harry potter book it's
like in harry potter it's like
it's a fictitious [ __ ] depiction of
something
well yeah but i know what you're saying
though it's just funny
anyway i can see that happening in other
countries a lot like i would imagine if
one of my cousins or whatever in vietnam
like they're less progressive
yeah yeah so if they're just like i
don't want to have kids i just want to
be a successful business woman they'd be
like she's crazy yeah
so then why isn't that funny how people
come for you
it's so [ __ ] funny she said that it
was just
really [ __ ] humiliating for these
gynecologists to be like no you're crazy
go see a psychologist like [ __ ] [ __ ]
you it's my body i'm telling you i do
not want to be
a mom ever in my life [ __ ] do this
procedure
so then she ended up doing some more
research and she found out that in her
country
it has been a guaranteed right since
2006
for 16 year olds and up to
get this procedure called tubal tube
tubal ligation
and and so she was like wait it's a
[ __ ]
right like you can't deny me this so
then she ended up going to a different
gynecologist and then
luckily like that gynecologist was like
oh yeah no problem like
let's [ __ ] do this so she did it and
now she's a 22 year old that got her
tube side
so for her she was just shocked at how
the doctors weren't
being just doctors about it like they
were just
being like oh something must be wrong
with you yes and they're putting their
own personal preference into their
practicing
i don't know argentinian culture i just
know that their barbecue
is [ __ ] bombed so good but i didn't
know that the wine is good too oh see i
don't drink i don't know
yeah but they they i guess um are they
still
i think it's argentina kind of like
where women
their pride and joy is the house and the
kids i guess what we're saying is has a
blue lagoon made it to that country yet
because they have why are you sitting on
me for blue lagoon
we took such a long time for that
reference and we thought it was going to
be something like
ground breaking and then it was like
it's like a movie did you see this movie
where they do this
yeah cool but y'all so i don't know give
me your input
give me your input so this is argentina
considered like a
uh like like like what do you call it
very traditional
i don't know anything about it yeah i
just i just know that there's conspiracy
that nazis ran away to argentina and
created a
community there yeah that's all i know i
don't know anything else
oh yeah i forgot about it well based off
of this story alone
and how they're they're reporting it
that it it's been like the talk of the
town in argentina
like this woman is like it's super
controversial for her to get her tube
side i'm assuming they're way more old
school they're just like oh
did you hear she doesn't want kids put
her in the mental asylum
is she in buenos aires uh i do not know
is that the one thing you could think of
the only city i know
that's the capital oh and then that
movie though don't cry for me argentina
oh yeah remember yeah evita avida
see okay okay uh uh silent mike is
argentina
tinian yeah yeah
that's all i know i don't know [ __ ] has
he has silent mike seen blue lagoon
he probably has hey guys i could text
him
[Laughter]
he probably seen evita though for sure
okay i'm talking [ __ ] about argentina
but i can see this happening in the
states
i can i can see this happening in like
people [ __ ] i don't know tennessee or
whatever or like even california if
you're in the wrong city because people
especially parents
who have narcissistic personality
disorder
they even if whatever your personal will
is they want to impose theirs on you
like carry on my lineage yeah you don't
want to have kids why are you punishing
me why are you [ __ ] my life up what's
wrong with you
yeah it's like well maybe i don't want
to do it because i want freedom
dude i see my friends with kids i'll be
honest half the time i'm like man this
does not look fun
it's not fun dude the first
year of this cat with tyka watching him
come to all of our gatherings
having to babysit this kid like in a
hyper way because the kid's trying to
kill himself without
just me chasing around the whole time
the whole time bart's walking the
perimeter of every [ __ ] party
having a miserable time it gets easier
and easier now yeah i noticed that
though
oh but they're so cute he's 12. he takes
care of himself the easiest
okay no now i have to deal with other
[ __ ] like attitudes and stuff
you've given me hope though because
initially i was like [ __ ]
this it's pretty fun though because then
then they start doing stuff that really
pulls at your heart strings like oh this
guy's cute as [ __ ]
that's why you guys it depends on like
your staging if you're ready for it
right because i see people
loving their uh parental duties and [ __ ]
and i see people that are like
[ __ ] bro i gotta run away from this [ __ ]
that's true i forgot to show you her
face there it is oh
the cream pie queen all right she loves
it she loves to do it
but bart do you love your childhood or
are you environmentally forced to love
your child
i love my crazy and i wanted to have
them and
has society made you love your child or
the blue lagoon
i think blue lagoon something was coming
there literally made me wish jill was my
cousin actually
don't watch blue lagoon don't watch it
[Music]
you